i think it's important to move
a little bit
every day
stretch
[Music]
what
welcome to painting with john season two
the show where i do not teach you how to
paint
[Music]
when season one of the show came out i
got so many people saying oh you live in
paradise you are so lucky
[Music]
i'm just thinking
it is paradise
but
we didn't show you the bad stuff
our washing
machine during the rainy season there's
these little map things they don't sting
you like a bee because you rattle this
nest on somebody they just sting you
because they're mean
the horror
[Music]
how do you like my boots
i haven't been sleeping so i have these
dark circles under my eyes and i imagine
that somebody would be flicking through
the channels and go honey there's a
talking raccoon on this channel
and he's painting
i have to be completely candid
i have these conversations in my head
when i'm painting we shot the first
season in all these reviews i'd like to
hang out with john laurie sometime
he seems like a good person to have a
beer with
but nobody who knows me wants to hang
out with me
[Music]
life can be pretty horrible
but they're also beautiful moments
i believe that human beings should shine
[Music]
shine from within
there's no ending to this story
so
thank you
[Music]